[Music]
Bachelorette Becca kufran is ready to do
the damn thing I wanted to be the best
thing about trying I can be it on
Wednesday host Chris Harrison took to
Instagram to debut The Bachelorette
Season 14 key arts featuring kufran
stunning in a one-shoulder silver gown
and matching heels and the words let's
do the damn thing in his caption
Harrison revealed the premiere date May
28th and we already know at least one
person who will be watching I can
comfortably watch
that's what Ari told et in March after
announcing his engagement to runner up
Lauren Burnham after fans watched the 36
year-old former racecar driver dumped
kufran while cameras were rolling we're
really hurt he was with the 28 year old
publicist at her Bachelorette photo
shoot last month here's what she said
about re watching her season I mean I
figured we actually we had had
conversations when we are sold together
like who do you think it could be as an
ex Bachelorette um so I figured he would
watch the show
production on kufran season of The
Bachelorette began in March and creator
Mike Fleiss is all about teasing us with
behind the scenes pic including this
photo from her first night of filming as
for who we can expect the brunette
beauty to end up with a source tells ET
she's simply looking for someone who is
loyal and honest with a great
personality adding quote we saw her ex
Ross gurgle on the show that's more her
physical type she likes handsome beefy
guys but ultimately she just wants
someone who's real
[Applause]
[Music]